[Musique]
qui a droit à la parole dans notre
société qui s'exprime sur le devant de
la scène
souvent très souvent les mêmes prenons
l'exemple de la jeunesse on la comprend
mal on parle du fossé des générations
c'est à l'évidence un monde clos fermé
un monde où pourtant l'on a des idées
forcément mais pas toujours différente
du monde des adultes
ce que nous vous proposons c'est
d'entendre ce monde tel qu'il s'est
exprimé quand nous lui avons donné la
parole sans restriction c'était à
l'occasion de l'organisation des 10% aux
lycées de lunel dans l'hérault
pourrais tu me dire aussi sur le plan
international un conflit éclate et est
ce que la non violence pourrait aboutir
à quelque chose tu parles d'un final
imagination non sérieusement
eh bien oui mais de façon à la
non-violence actuellement menée
pratiquement rien du tout donc tu
imagines dans l'hypothèse d'un conflit
est ce que l'ambiance serait efficace
oui moi personnellement je dis oui cela
actuellement on ne peut pas du tout dire
bon est ce qui est ce qu'ils ont
accompli faudrait tous est remis en juin
on n'y est pas préparé alors c'est ici
que se pose aussi le problème de savoir
si la violence nécessaire
deux invités pour ce thème face aux
lycéens le premier
non violent j'entends pas de carrière
militaire d'accord mais je pense qu'on a
toujours besoin d'une armée premièrement
pour se défendre parce que je ne pense
pas que la non violence puis sabots ou
alors à ce moment là si vous voulez des
mythes ayral si on veut être démis et
militariser la lafa ce moment là il faut
démilitarisé le monde
considérez vous avez assez d'éléments
d'appréciation pour a évidemment ggp a
vécu j'ai pas vous pouvez les mains je
suis bien d'accord mais je vois pas
pourquoi j'attends d'en avant des
aimants en avoir vécu de leur fils girl
pour raconter à mes enfants mais vous
verrez quand vous aurez mon âge et c'est
un bon visage et j'ai compris certains
trucs je vais essayer de jouer essayer
de continuer je vois pas pourquoi
peut-être que quand j'aurai pris de la
bouteille d'accord ça passe tant mieux
mais en attendant pensez que c'est un
jugement vous pourrez remettront commune
a toujours je sais pas du tout comment
je réagirais en cas de conflit en cas de
conflit militaire dans le train de
perdre comme free fait un intérieur dans
un pays où enfin dans la france pour
notre pays je sais pas du tout comment
je réagirais pour l'instant j'essaie de
m'éduquer
c'est pas en rupture avec mon milieu
familial mais le contraire est ce que
vous ne pensez pas alors que vous êtes
le d'être le fruit d'une certaine
éducation qui l'a amené à penser cela ou
alors est ce que c'est vraiment une
opinion vous êtes venge en plus c'est
une opinion un tir au but personnel
bon mais parra ne sommes pas contre et
je ne dis pas qu'ils sont pour mais bien
qu'ils ne sont pas contre c'est du pit
plus jeune âge quoi je pensais qu'on
avait besoin d'une armée et vous ne
pensez pas que certaines conditions du
milieu ont pilonné avancer cela non plus
bon beaucoup ont essayé de nous
persuader vôtre beaucoup m'ont dit
pourquoi abattus à l'armé pourquoi nous
sépare mas et ses larmes et ça me plaît
pas mais vous parlez tous ici un peu
pour le moment de la violence des arbres
disant oui il ya d'autres formes de
violence dans l'exemple la violence
administrative
oui oui nos mais la violence de l'êta
sur des citoyens par exemple vous avez
commencé et je considère tout aussi
nocive que la violence des armes
seulement parlent surtout de violence
venant des armes parce que c'est celle
qui a plus flagrante
[Musique]
second interlocuteur il a renvoyé son
livret militaire à la suite de la sphère
du larzac ton style qu'il s'agisse d'un
exemple à suivre
bah oui parce que parce que j'estime au
corps en est à une époque où la violence
est vraiment un beaucoup trop forte
étant déjà non viola moi même je trouve
que c'est de la désobéissance civile est
très valable et a donné que nous avons
là nous sommes le troisième pays en
armement et je trouve que c'est presque
une haute
c'est même une honte j'ai honte d'être
dans ce pays qui va désormais pas
n'importe qui à tort et à travers
alors c'est une des faces rome dans la
désobéissance civile non violente
le refus de collaborer les arbres ça
correspond à des conflits sa
correspondante en parle vietnam on sait
de quoi on parle
quand on parle de l'algérie bon moi je
n'ai pas vécu mais je sais qui c'est
passé des des atrocités là bas qu'on est
que que c'est là qu'on a torturé et
c'est qu'on a perpétué les tortures du
nazim haut mais je ne sais pas si c'est
une violence vraiment sacré vos yeux et
si vous m avez par exemple quelqu'un qui
est comme on dit dans la misère
considérer que c'est une victime
il a suivi une violence économique elle
est aussi barbare que l'autre est tout
aussi puisque lll aliens complètement le
slogan à tel point d'en faire quelqu'un
qui réagit devant nous sommes plus rien
qui est plus capable de dix ans ni oui
ni non qui fait savoir les choses parce
que bon il faut bien vivre faut bien
manger mais c'est tout il en vient plus
à pleurer aucune décision plus aucune
responsabilité dans la société actuelle
tout le monde est conditionné par
exemple je prends par exemple matin je
me lève je suis militaire matin je me
lève je salue mon goût mandat dans la
société
le matin un ouvrier se lève il va voir
son patron il dit bonjour je suis bien
d'accord
ensuite le commandant me dit de faire
quelque chose dont je suis obligé de le
faire je suis payé pour ceux ci pour ça
bon le proviseur par exemple je prends
sur le lycée le proviseur dit un truc un
professeur le proviseur le professeur
seront automatiquement obligé de le
faire et le patron c'est pareil patron
ordonne à l'ouvrier ouvriers fait
automatiquement tout le monde est
conditionnée et s'ils ne connaissent pas
grand chose qu'on pourrait discuter
il est sûr que nous tous nous
connaissons beaucoup moins encore la non
violence que la violence je crois
justement que il y a des possibilités
nouvelles qui s'offrent dans la
perspective de la non violence
à partir de là je dirais que c'est une
fonction d'information qui peut être la
mienne dans la mesure où les
circontances - né d'une part à moi-même
étudier ce problème et à m'engager
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors autant par la imaginaire un pays
attaqueraient la france
non tu irais aux frontières toi et on
fera quoi sans armes
penses tu que les adversaires resterait
comme ça sur la frontière ou plutôt
attaquer rit-il au contraire je moi je
pense qu'ils en profiteraient ils
profiteraient de votre impuissance à
pouvoir vous attaquer je sais pas je
crois que c'est plutôt un faux problème
contraire dans les écoutes en 38
critères a déclaré la guerre notre arme
même s était pratiquement rien du tout
par rapport aux allemands alors moi je
te le dis franchement il y aurait par
exemple un autre type comme iter à la
tête d'un quelconque pays
vous verrez arriver césar mais j'en
profiterais encore plus la non violence
il vous posséderez il vous exploiterez
tous ceux qui penseraient c'est tout
d'accord tu cites et idem en gtc jours
au monde ne peut plus et la guerre de 14
quand les français ont voulu déclarer la
guerre allemagne jean jaurès jean jaurès
en france qui était socialiste a voulu à
voulu faire a demandé aux ouvriers la
grève générale la grève générale
c'est un moyen non violent bon il
demandé aux ouvriers français aux
ouvriers allemands de s'unir entre eux
pour refuser d'aller à la guerre qu'est
ce qui s'est passé jean jaurès et faire
assassiner
moralité appartient au moment où il
s'est fait assassiner tout le monde
le mouvement s'est arrêté tout le monde
est parti sur le front et à partir du
moment où tu commences à l'eswc france
que tu sens non violente pas partir du
moment où il ya un gars qui fusille et
que tu commences à canarder mais c'est
sûr qu'il ya des morts tu peux pas faire
autrement
c'est pas parce que tu arrives au non
violent que tu dis oh maintenant je suis
non viola ne me tire pas dessus les
règles on ne tire dessus et tu penses tu
que tu as à convaincre beaucoup de gens
je cherchais pas à les convaincre
je cherche surtout pas commun que j'ai
reçus tout d'abord à vivre d'une manière
non violente
parce que je crois qu'une manière de
vivre le témoignage pas par la façon de
vivre c'est le plus probant plus que des
belles paroles et plus que j'essaie de
ne les convainc de plus que ce que je
fais
[Musique]